طرفه الحربي في اوكرانيا يواصلني رمي
اوراقهما على طاوله المعركه الجانبان
يسابقان الزمن للتقدم على الارض القوه
الروسيه تسعى لتحقيق مكاسب قبل وصول
الدبابات الغربيه التي قد تغير ديناميكيه
الحرب موسكو تضغط شرقا والكلام هنا عن
بخمه اونجليدار التغلغل الروسي الاعمق
امام خيارين الى ثالث لهما اما مواصله
قتال الشوارع الدموي وماله من كلفه بشريه
او الانسحاب للحفاظ على القوه
فالجيش الاوكراني يسيطر على اراضي مرتفعه
الى الغرب من المدينه يسهل الدفاع عنها
منطقه اكتسبت اهميه رمزيه في الاشهر
الاخيره حيث تسعى روسيا الى توسيع قبضتها
على الشرقيه ككل الهجمه الروسيه تاتي في
الوقت الذي تحولت الحرب الى سلسله من
المعارك الطاحنه على طول خطوط امام ثابته
النسبيا مع عدم امتلاك اي من الجانبين
افضليه واضحه
القوه الروسيه تحاول تقدم اكثر قبل وصول
الدبابات الغربيه سلاح تعول عليه اوكرانيا
لمساعدتها على اختراق الخطوط الروسيه
واستعاده المزيد من الاراضي باعتبارها
اقوى من الطرازه القديمه لدى موسكو في
الوقت نفسه تعتمد روسيا على العدد الكبير
من الجنود بعد التعبئه الجزئيه بالاضافه
الى مجموعه
بلال البوجدين العربيه